hello everyone first let me start with
our sincere apologies we had some
technical difficulties but we sure
appreciate you hanging in there we are
ready to begin the broadcast and we're
so pleased to have you join us for
cardinal health lab exchange today's
broadcast is patient safety I'm Brenda
Kelly Kim elaborate and I'll be your
moderator for today's webinar and we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by the american society for
clinical laboratory science the AFC LS
the mission of AFC LS is to make a
positive impact in health care through
leadership that will assure excellence
in the practice of laboratory medicine
for more information please visit WWE we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this presentation has
been approved for continuing education
credits please click on the c/e button
at the bottom left corner of the
auditorium this will direct you to the
necessary site and form needed to
receive your credit this webcast is also
designed to be interactive and we
encourage you to ask questions you can
submit your questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button the
lower left of the presentation window
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation hopefully not
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problem to the
green Q&A button will relax following
this presentation if you have time head
on over to the community of learning in
the lab exchange lobby to have the
opportunity to engage in live chat and
have more their questions answered on
the spot about patients basis now for
today's speaker Susan Morris Susan
Morris has been the patient safety
officer at st. Luke's Magic Valley
Medical Center since 2006 prior to that
she was the director of ancillary
services for five years after serving as
the laboratory manager for the
institution in her current position she
manages the performance improvement and
patient safety education for this
200-bed Regional Medical Center
including facilitation of root cause
analysis team and conducting failure
mode and effects analysis she has more
than 30 years experience in working and
managing hospital laboratories is a past
president of the American Society for
Clinical Laboratory science past
president of the National credentialing
agency for laboratory personnel and a
current member of the board of governors
of the ascp Board of certification she
has numerous publications on improving
patient safety health care quality and
delivery and employing IOM patient
safety competencies to introduce quality
improvement processes to medical
laboratory ins I'll now turn it over to
Susan for her presentation good morning
everyone I'm so glad to be joining you
today and talking about patient safety
and how its really impacted by
laboratory professionals I'm going to be
talking a little today about the
difference between patient safety and
laboratory safety I've worked in medical
labs most of my career before
transitioning to working full-time in
patient safety for the past eight years
in my day-to-day activities I often
think back on my own experience in the
laboratory and how the patient safety
Lessing lessons I'm learning today would
apply in that environment when I entered
the laboratory profession I was it was
widely believed that errors were not
allowed in the workplace if an error did
occur emphasis was playing on blaming
the individual with the assumption they
most likely were not following
procedures as they were taught my
experience in patient safety has taught
me that it's really important to create
a culture of safety within the
laboratory that really acknowledges the
reality that all humans will make errors
and prioritizes learning from those
errors how we can identify and fix
faulty processes that may prevail cream
may fail to prevent errors or keep them
from being detected and corrected before
they resulted in unintended
to patients I'll also share with you
some ways the laboratory professionals
can impact patient safety by extending
their involvement on to
interdisciplinary teams so errors can
and really do happen in healthcare and
in laboratory practice let me give you
one example a 57 year old woman had an
order for four units of fresh frozen
plasma to be transfused following
surgery this patient was blood type a
positive so to a pause FFP units were
thawed and transfused and she tolerated
this well orders were then given to
transfuse another two units John who was
the medical lab scientist scheduled in
the blood bank that day was in the
process of performing a stat cross match
for a patient in the emergency
department but he quickly went to the
plasma freezer which happened to be
located two rooms down the hall removed
two units of press of frozen plasma and
then took them back to the blood bank
where he placed them into the water bath
to thaw then going back to his emergency
cross match he finished that and
notified the ED that the blood was ready
and then he went to lunch oh but before
leaving he reported off that there were
two units of plasma falling to Marsha
the MLS who was covering the blood bank
while he was going to be gone so Marsha
removed the plasma from the bath labeled
them for the patient and checked them
out to the nursing assistant who was
sent over to pick them up both plasma
units were 0 positive Marsha did not
notice the discrepancy between the
plasma blood type and the patient's
blood type she usually depended on the
blood bank computer system which would
pick that up for her but in this case
there had been a major update that week
of the computer system and the
functionality for alerting the blood
type discrepancy had not been tested
after the update and it was not
functioning and failed to detect the
error to our ends there
the patient identified identification
and match the blood products to the
patient's order however they didn't
understand the difference between red
cells and plasma and assumed that it
would not be a problem to transfuse the
typo plasma to a type a patient because
they'd learned that type O blood was the
universal donor they didn't call the
blood bank to clarify after the plasma
was transfused the patient's hemoglobin
level was rechecked and it had dropped
by 2 grams the patient received three
units of blood and eventually stabilized
this was an error that started as a
series of human errors in the laboratory
but then continued to not be recognized
or stopped due to the fall keep
processes in the information system and
with the nursing processes so this is an
example in the laboratory world of an
error that actually happened so this
epidemic of harm from medical errors
continues to happen across the country
and was the basis for the Institute of
Medicine breakthrough report in 1999
which focused the attention of the
country on preventing harm that was
caused by medical mistakes so here we
are 15 years later and really patients
are not any safer now than they were in
1999 when an airliner crashes like the
recent tragedy in the French Alps many
lives are lost in a single day we saw an
international response to that event of
grief outrage and fear and yet there are
275 lives lost every single day in the
United States from health care errors
many of them preventable and there's
little or no public recognition of this
the evolution of our present-day
healthcare delivery system has led to
unintended
of huge numbers of patients and their
families so what is patient safety it is
actually harm to patients associated
with their health care laboratory safety
is related to preventing employees from
harm from the hazards in the workplace
that would be chemicals blood and body
fluid exposure fire prevention disposal
of hazardous materials those kinds of
things patient safety emphasizes
reporting analysis and Prevention of
health care errors that can lead to
patient harm the Institute of medicines
report to err is human and crossing the
quality chasm both raised public
awareness that patients are being harmed
at alarming rates from the healthcare
that really was intended to help them
this was shocking to most healthcare
leaders at that time who believed that
we had the safest healthcare system in
the world patient safety is all about
the patient not the employee and really
it is our professional obligation to
take patient safety as our first
priority and do all that we can to work
in the work environment to protect
patients from errors that may be caused
from by us so health care culture as its
developed is traditionally physician
centric organizational structures place
them at the top and gives them authority
over the rest of the team now this
authority is usually not written into
policy but is firmly ingrained in
workplace culture so staff may be
reluctant to speak up if they have a
safety concern over time health care
specialties developed into separate
units of expertise within the system and
laboratories are one such unit many labs
exist as a silo of knowledge separated
from the rest of the healthcare
by lack of communication which
contributes to fragmented care we're
working side by side but not together
from the laboratory professionals
perspective our role on the patient care
team is to provide answers to diagnostic
and treatment planning questions
laboratory information is often time
critical in decision-making that can
save a patient's life or prevent harm as
members of the healthcare team we also
have opportunities to identify potential
process failure areas where errors might
occur and we must speak up if we see
such a problem we have a responsibility
to work with other members of the
healthcare team to find solutions and
that'll make our process safer this kind
of contribution requires a different
skill set than our current technical
competencies one year following the to
err is human report the Institute of
Medicine followed up by publishing
crossing the quality chasm which
described a vision of what ideal quality
healthcare system of the 21st century
should look like the report outlined six
aims or characteristics that are
necessary to achieve quality health care
that report described the ideal health
care system as care that is safe timely
effective efficient equitable and
patient-centered it also stated that all
healthcare professionals were not being
adequately prepared to provide the
highest quality and safety medical care
needs to ensure patient safety
laboratory services should address each
of those six IOM aims for providing
quality care so what would that look
like safe laboratory care provides
accurate data
it's reported on the correct patient
reported to the appropriate care
provider timely laboratory care means
that the information is available when
it's needed to make care decisions and
interventions effective laboratory care
appropriate tests are utilized to get
the information needed efficient
laboratory care eliminating waste and
controlling costs of care equitable
laboratory care perhaps that would be
providing interpreter services for
non-english speaking patients so that
all have equal access and
patient-centered laboratory care might
be answering patient questions about the
tests they are receiving there was a
Health Professions education summit that
was convened by the Institute of
Medicine following its to initial
reports to develop strategies on how to
build the necessary skills into the
education of health professionals and
that would be the key to improving
quality and safety so the findings from
that pub summit were published in 2003
and that was called a bridge to quality
and they all agreed that the one reason
for patient harm is that health
professionals simply are not prepared
during their clinical training to master
some competencies that they identified
as essential to achieving the 16th so
the missing competencies were providing
patient-centered care using
evidence-based medicine using quality
improvement principles use of
informatics and working on
interdisciplinary teams so I'd like to
stop for a second here and take a quick
poll Brenda will put on for us about I'd
like to know if your clinical training
covered the six quality aims or the five
healthcare competencies
so you can answer yes or no
so Brenda how does how do we move from
this pole on we just felt can be shared
should showing up on screen for
attendees in just a moment there there
we go alright so twenty five point nine
percent said yes that is fantastic that
means we are making some progress and
the majority have not been trained which
is not not a surprise at this point okay
so close the poll okay so um I'd like to
talk a little bit nor more now about
each of these competencies and so how
would they look in the laboratory
environment so let's start with becoming
patient-centered providing patient care
in the best possible quality is really
central to our profession although it
may not have been thought about as a
competency or skill so patient
involvement really has been widely
recognized as an effective way to
prevent errors so that means patients
should be actively involved not passive
while receiving services from the
laboratory no one is more invested than
the patient and making sure that nothing
goes wrong with their care there's all
kinds of documents and websites found on
the internet that share patient stories
and those patients are really committed
to helping other patients become engaged
in their healthcare this report came
from the National Patient Safety
Foundation but there are many others out
there so providing patient-centered
laboratory care means designing access
to care and services that is best for
the patient not necessarily what is most
convenient for the care providers
patient-centered laboratory
professionals would check for
understanding with their patients by
using techniques such as teach back that
ask the patient or their advocate who's
with them to verbalize just what it was
they heard of the information you just
told them and then also encouraging
patients to ask questions if you haven't
seen this before you definitely need to
take a look at this website lab tests
online it is a wonderful
patient-centered public resource on
clinical lab testing and the information
on this website it gives patients all
kinds of information about most
laboratory tests in understandable
language the content is peer reviewed
and non-commercial and patients can also
post questions that they have about
their tests or their results and they'll
get an email response from a laboratory
professional answering their questions
so this is a great resource to give out
to your patients also on the AFC LS web
site there are patient-centered
materials that you can customize for
your laboratory to make up some patient
education materials they are easily
customizable templates where you can put
your laboratory logo on there and it's
available in English and Spanish for
most of these laboratories can customize
them so that they become their own so
this is gives you a head start on how to
get some materials ready for your
patience oops and let's see a skip there
we go this is another one you ought to
take a look at is the Joint Commission
website has a series of brochures called
speak up and this was a campaign they
did together with CMS to give patients
information in understandable language
about their health care and they have
one this one that i'm showing you here
is called laboratory serve
but the messages are very similar
between the laboratory brochures and
other healthcare brochures for this
series and they have messages such as
don't be afraid to ask about safety
quality or how long it takes to get
results don't be afraid to tell the
health professional if you think they've
confused you with another patient make
sure your sample is labeled with your
full name and another piece of
identifying information when it is
collected so really helps empower the
patients to have permission to speak up
patient-centered laboratories
communicate significant results promptly
and as directly as possible to the
ordering physician and they tell
patients about when they can expect that
their physician will have those test
results they also explain to them how
they can get a copy of their results and
CMS now requires laboratories to make
results available to patients in some
cases patients are told by their
physicians that if you don't hear
anything for me it means that their lab
results were normal however there's many
things that can go wrong with that
process no news is not always good news
for patients 1 38 year old man was
diagnosed with an abdominal mass he
chose to refer be referred to a
well-known highly respected major
medical system in another state for the
surgery and all went well with a
surgical procedure the tumor was removed
and sent to pathology the patient was
able to return home within 48 hours but
the final report ology report had not
yet been received by the surgeon he told
the patient he was confident that no
additional treatment would be necessary
to just consider no news to be good news
he would only need to contact them if
there was unexpected findings in the
pathology report the pathologist had
identified some malignant cells
specimen and ordered additional special
stains to complete the diagnosis
delaying the final report when
pathologists attempted to call the
findings to the surgeon he learned that
he had left town that morning for a
three-week vacation the report was sent
to the surgeons clinic but was
accidently misfiled along with another
patients records one year later the
patient had a recurrence of symptoms and
at that time he was found to have
metastatic disease he died six months
later his widow has now become an
international advocate for patient
engagement in their healthcare using
evidence-based practice methods is
another of the IOM competencies that is
essential for providing quality health
care eliminating outdated lab methods
from the test menu and implementing new
practice methods is an ongoing
responsibility to ensure that physicians
are ordering tests that are effective
laboratory professionals have a
responsibility to their patients to read
journals and stay current with new
developments in laboratory science in
addition laboratory professionals should
be providing education to providers and
other healthcare professionals on best
practices and algorithms for ordering
laboratory tests laboratory
professionals should be participating on
interdisciplinary protocol teams that
are implementing research proven best
practices this might include a
transfusion team a sepsis protocol team
a stroke protocol team or perhaps an
antibiotic stewardship team lab
professionals should also be
participating on interdisciplinary teams
that are developing diagnostic
algorithms the majority of healthcare
errors are the result of faulty
processes so using quality improvement
principles the third confidence
he identified by the institute of
medicine is essential to develop a
continuous improvement mentality
continuing and measuring the quality of
the care that we deliver in terms of
structure process and the outcomes for
patients will lead to the design of
improvements that can prevent unintended
harm to patients so data collection and
analysis of quality indicators is the
key to this tracking trending and also
analyzing those errors are necessary to
find the improvement process as needed
and reducing future errors the Joint
Commission's National Patient Safety
goals focus on the best practice
processes that have they have data on
that affect preventing errors for
high-risk and error-prone processes so
some of those would include verifying
too patient identifiers to prevent test
information going to the wrong patient
or also timely communication of critical
results when delays and treatment could
cause serious harm in order to learn
about and study errors laboratories must
support a culture that allows staff to
feel safe to report errors there are
algorithms available such as the just
culture which can help guide managers in
supporting staff who report errors while
still holding staff accountable when
there's a trend of bad choices of
reckless behavior and then there's also
the root cause analysis opportunities to
dig into those errors after they've
happened and understand how did it
happen where did things go wrong and
what could we do to keep that process on
track so that this couldn't happen again
or be much harder to happen again in the
future
so we do need to use a scientific
approach when we're changing processes
once we have analyzed and found the
underlying problems we need to test
those solutions before a widespread
distribution of a new process we can
also be proactive in our risk analysis
and look at processes that we think have
a high likelihood of going to having an
error and just brainstorm what are the
things we could do to possibly prevent
that from happening and straight
strengthen those processes the method
that I use for that is called FMEA
failure mode and effects analysis so
with your basic improvement model you
have some fundamental questions you're
trying to answer what is it that we're
trying to prevent what are we trying to
accomplish here what changes can we make
that will result in an improvement that
will make it harder for that to happen
and how will we know that the change is
actually made an improvement so that is
when you do the PDSA process you plan
your improvement you do a trial on a
small scale to see if how it's going to
work and then you study how how did that
work out was there unexpected problems
that came up that we need to adjust the
process somewhat and then you fully
implement your new process data is
essential for convincing others that
change has been successful in achieving
the goal so by identifying what you're
going to measure and then collecting
that data before and after the change is
put in place you'll end up with evidence
that can be shared with others in the
organization and I've heard it said that
physicians will respond to data when
they won't respond to reason so it's a
very strong tool for changing behaviors
in the organization
you also want to display your data over
time so that you can see at the point
where you put in your implement your
intervention whether that will show you
the point where the data should be
changing and getting better and you look
for at least three consecutive months of
data meeting the target to confirm that
the improvement has actually been a
success and then after that point you
can go to periodic checks just to verify
that it's being sustained the fourth
competency that's essential for health
care quality in our current information
age is the ability to effectively use
informatics laboratory professionals
need to become experts in the resources
and methods for the management of health
information to give you an example of
how disconnected transfer of information
can lead to patient harm I can tell you
about one situation where an abnormal
troponin result was discovered by the
medical unit charge nurse several hours
after the report had printed on their
computer in this small rural hospital
paper reports were printed from the lab
computer system and then placed on to
patients paper charts several times each
day for the physician to review when
they came to do their rounds on their
patients because it was difficult for
the lab to determine when an elevated
troponin result would require action it
had not been included on the critical
values policy so the result was not
called to the ordering physician the
charge nurse alerted cardiologists of
the result as soon as she found it but
that was later in the afternoon since
time is muscle with the cardiac patients
it was now the cardiologists decision to
call in the cardiac cath team and
proceed to an emergency cardiac cath
procedure a repeat troponin was ordered
but the results were not received until
the cast procedure was completed the
second troponin level was normal it was
later determined that the original
specimen
had contained fibrin clots which caused
false positive on the test results
following the unnecessary invasive
procedure the patient said she was at
least relieved to learn that her heart
was actually normal but she was exposed
to a very risky procedure unnecessarily
competency in using informatics includes
designing and building connected
information systems that make a
patient's laboratory data available to
the electronic medical record system
across the continuum of care it also
includes appropriately using electronic
methods to facilitate quick and
effective communication within the
healthcare team informatics skills would
also be useful in researching
publications and best practices and also
this is a convenient means for assessing
content accessing continuing education
to maintain competency and professional
certification there may be future
opportunities for laboratory
professionals in developing apps for
smartphones for laboratory information
the final competency and possibly the
most important of the five is working on
interdisciplinary teams the Joint
Commission has identified gaps in
coordination and communication between
health professionals as the number one
contributing factor to Sentinel events
some common examples of
interdisciplinary teams in hospitals
including a code blue response team or
an antimicrobial stewardship team you
may be able to think of others if you're
not already involved in one of these
types of teams you might start by
thinking about what are the key areas
you interact with frequently in your
work these are the areas you need to be
closely connected two teams function by
using simple teamwork skills and that
start with getting to know each other by
name and always treating each other with
mutual
expect even within the laboratory
environment there are probably groups
that you depend on as part of your work
but that you don't spend time as a team
talking about how well your current
processes are functioning for all
involved thinking of yourselves as a
team is an important first step that
means you all understand you can achieve
better outcomes when you work together
as a team most of us have not had formal
training on how to be part of a team you
may have had some kind of sports team
experience at some point in your life
but probably not related to your
workplace team behavior can be greatly
improved for some focused training that
identifies the necessary skills and
allows team members to practice those
behaviors until it feels comfortable and
natural simulation-based tree training
and games provide opportunities in a
realistic setting some lifelike terrain
to practice those interactions and
dynamic situations you can practice
getting and giving feedback and learn
how to give others permission to give
you feedback making it feel safe for
them to do so and decreasing defensive
behaviors without this kind of training
and practice team members usually lack
the required behavior repertoire to
perform effectively teamstepps is a
teamwork training system developed by
healthcare professionals in the
Department of Defense's patient safety
program in collaboration with HR q the
agency for Healthcare Research and
quality it includes a comprehensive set
of ready to use materials and training
curriculum to successfully integrate
teamwork principles into any healthcare
system more information is available on
the age
RQ HHS gov website and this information
is free and available the curriculum
covers four primary so it covers for
primary trainable teamwork skills
leadership communication situation
monitoring and mutual support the team
leaders learn how to define clarify and
instill team goals and objectives
effectively communicate methods so that
teams learn to develop shared mental
models they make shared decisions and
then they dynamically adapt to their
priorities cross monitoring means
watching each other's back this skill
clearly separates a real team from a
group of angels individuals who just
happen to work in the same general
location team members learn to practice
backup behavior so when they do that
they kind of pay attention to what is
going on around them if there is a
period of high workload or you're short
staffed there's a greater chance that
somebody on the team might make an error
so team members are constantly aware of
that situation they anticipate what's
coming next they watch out for each
other and they appropriately correct
actions to prevent errors from reaching
a patient in team training the team
members practice exchanging and
accepting feedback from another one
another it has to be more than just a
rating of oh you did good or that was
bad it should be diagnostic and
constructive and give them an indication
of what they can do to improve
in this quote from William Mayo founder
of the Mayo Clinic we can see that as
early as 1910 laboratory professionals
were recognized as essential members of
interdisciplinary healthcare teams it's
become necessary to develop medicine as
a cooperative science the clinician the
specialist and the laboratory workers
uniting for the good of the patient each
assisting in elucidation of the problem
at hand and each dependent upon the
other for support in the ideal patient
safety culture optimal safe care is
everyone's overarching and
non-negotiable goal no one is ever
hesitant to voice a concern about a
patient because it is psychologically
safe to do so there's a simple model of
accountability that clearly
differentiates unsafe individuals from
competent conscientious individuals who
fall victim to system errors and we're
constantly learning from the errors that
happen so that we can make our process
is safer preventing harm to future
patients who depend on laboratory
professionals to keep them safe so I'll
stop now and allow some time for
questions thank you very much Susan for
that informative presentation I'm so
happy you were able to be with us at
Cardinal Health live exchange and before
we get started with questions I'm just
going to remind our audience how to
submit them you can submit your
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green QA button on the lower left of the
presentation window and we're going to
try to get to as many questions as we
can through that process and I'd like to
thank the audience again for hanging in
with us on our technical issues we did
have to start a few minutes late but
we're glad that you folks are all here
and we're able to listen to Susan's
presentation okay I'm I'm not seeing any
questions in our in our QA q how
ever we would like to remind you to head
on over to the community of learning
following today's presentation and
that's an opportunity you have to engage
in live chat with Susan okay here we do
actually have a question great talk
Susan can you elaborate on any current
research regarding errors etc that are
reduced by interprofessional that are
reduced by interprofessional teams
including labs thank you for that
question I am not aware of any research
in that field right now which is
problematic of course but it is an
opportunity for us to be looking at and
perhaps doing some research to document
the impact of that we are kind of in the
early ages of this patient safety field
and there's not a lot out there to
support it where it's just opportunity
for research at this time great thanks
for that answer and and again susan has
graciously agreed to be part of our
community of learning following today's
presentation and we have another
question coming in can you repeat the
website for the AHRQ again oh sure just
a second here let me look in my notes
too many notes here i believe is HR q
HHS gov but I just need to sign that
if you put in a shark you in your search
engine it'll come up easily so just try
Brad great we have another question with
a paperless workplace today what is your
suggestion for how to deal with samples
that come to the lab without electronic
orders without any orders then I would
imagine well they would probably in your
paperless system you're going to have to
have some kind of paper label on those
samples so you're labeling system
probably is where you're going to have
your fallback as to where they came from
and be able to research that great thank
you I think that's all we have but the
community of learning Susan will be
there to answer any more of your burning
questions about patient safety today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through October of this year and
you'll receive an email from labrada you
when this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
announcement Jenny collie it may have
missed today's live event thank you very
much again for joining us Thank You
Susan for your presentation today we'll
see you next time bye